drug addiction is a disease of the brain
it's a disease of the brain we don't put
people that have diseases in the jail or
in prison because they actually that's
we decide right i mean this person is
actually has has a what type of disease
i actually i don't even dare myself to
the concept of of putting someone on
jail because they have a diseases my
brain doesn't even allow me to think
that way and yet that we do that with
addicted people and and I've thought a
lot why why is our society criminalizing
the person that's addicted to drugs and
I think it's because it has been very
hard for people to recognize that our
behaviors and our ability to control our
desires it's basically the product of
very complex systems in the brain that
enable us to perceive these desires to
control them to make the right choices
this is very difficult for people that
have all of their faculties intact to
understand that not everybody can do it
and and so I sort of easier to say well
if I can do it that person is not doing
it because they are choosing to just
have a good time and so we've taken that
approach and and I guess the other
element that happens with drugs the the
drive to take these drugs can be so
overpowering so so overpowering because
it's hardwired in the brain as the
signaling is this is something that is
necessary for survival that's what drugs
have done in a person that's addicted
they've generated the message as the
same intense as if you haven't eaten and
and it's a signal you have to eat or
you'll dry or your diet you have to
drink water or you'll die very very
powerful signals very difficult to
control when you you have anything for
one week and you have full in front of
you just try to say no to that for this
it's the same drive so it they can when
they are in those situation this intense
drive they can do behaviors that are
criminal they can go and still you know
are to be able to get that wrong like
someone who has not eaten for one week
if they have nothing but to steal the
food they may steal the food so that
that leads to the criminal behavior that
then leads the person and the system to
react very negatively you should not
steal of course you should not steal but
people should not be hungry people
should not be on that situation that
they have to steal in order to it that
should not happen like a person should
not be not given treatment that is in a
situation where their bodies
experiencing that draw as if it were a
survival knee they should be provided
with treatment so yes we should deal
with drug addiction as a disease like we
deal with any of the other medical
diseases we should not be criminalizing
it when we criminalize the drug addict
and nobody wins certainly you're not
going to improve the behavior of the
person that is thrown into jail when
they get out of the jail the first thing
they'll do is relapse unless you treat
them in jail if you treat them in jail
and you maintain the treatment when they
leave jail then you are giving them a
chance what if you're throwing them in
jail and not providing any treatment or
treating them in jail and then throwing
them out they will relapse so and that
costs an enormous amount of money to put
people on jail because they are addicted
to drugs it's very very costly it's not
doesn't make any sense you your tax
dollar goes into the criminal justice
system is much less expensive to treat
and if you treat that person you're
giving that person a chance and you're
giving the family of that person a
chance so it's a win-win you basically
decrease your cross on criminal behavior
you decrease rain conservation and the
person can go back and become an active
member of society at all levels
you